Uh, we also saw something the other day that I really liked.
I cried and it's my beautiful octopus to lover. What's it called?
Oh, then my octopus teacher.
Teacher, my guy who see it, no with my Lord.
I don't know if it will hit people a certain way or maybe the way,
the way it hit me was like a dump truck. It hit me in ways. I don't,
I didn't think was sure.
It was such a about it. She's like, you know, you're just not,
you're not the type to cry over stuff like this. You don't have feelings.
And I'm like, what? I'm a feeler baby. Right.
And I saw it and it was very emotional and I,
and I vowed today publicly that I will never eat
calamari or octopus again. Interesting.
Never again. I can't cuddle fish. Yes. Eat the out of cuddles.
It's just the same, babe. Cuddle fish are just as intelligent and sentience.
Does that have a Netflix special that they don't have?
What are your favorite animals of all time to eat?
No, but can we talk about the thing and I'll get into that. Okay.
I don't know what it's about. Yeah.
I'll tell you what it's about some South African man, right?
He has a midlife crisis. Okay. And I guess he's, I'm involved in, um, he's uh,
either a director or a videographer. He produces like documentarian or whatever.
And he does animal. How you call it with, say a chart documentarian. And he, he,
he has a midlife crisis. It's the work is too overwhelming.
So he decides just to it all and take a break.
So he moves back to the beach house that he grew up in with his family,
right. Something like that, something like that. It's in South Africa,
it's right on the low. And he decides to, um,
swim every day, right. In the, um, tip of South Africa.
And this is the Cove. And, um,
he starts documenting things with his cameras and he doesn't do it with a scuba
Deere D gear. Oh wow. Yeah. And one day he, um,
spots a, um,
an octopus and he goes back
and obviously the, at first the octopus, like what the?
I've never seen a white dude in my life that, what is he doing here?
So he builds this. He builds,
he builds an obsession for this 200 meter plot of
underwater real estate, basically.
And so he builds an obsession and he goes to this,
this same little Cove every day for like 350 days.
Then what happens is this octopus obviously is frightened by this.
You know what I mean? Initially, initially, and then they develop a friendship.
What? Yeah,
it's really sad to the point where the octopus will throw
out her technical arm and wrap it around his finger to say hello,
or the octopus follows him. She follows him.
The octopus will come and land on his chest and greet them. Hello.
So sad, you know? And, um, there's so much drama. I don't want to get away,
give it away and no stroller. It's a very dramatic it's so well shot. So, well.
If you're just a lover of nature,
like even before the octopus story was introduced,
the moment he described, like, um, being underwater,
like flying, I was already crying.
Yeah. It it's, it's one of those, um, movies where you,
I think I there's, some people, you know, that aren't animal people.
Like for me, you know, when I look at my dogs or my cats in the eyes, right.
There's a definite connection I have, I know there's a comedy podcast,
but I want to get real for a second, you know?
And I literally love them right. More than I love most humans.
Like I there's like a spiritual connection that I have, you know,
when I see any of my dog's eyes and we connect in that way,
it fills me with such warmth and enjoy. And it, it gives me, um,
a reason to live well, actually, you know, and it's like,
I can understand how a man, you know what I mean?
We'll go underwater and bond and connect with another creature in
that way. Especially in an intelligent,
they say that an octopus is as smart as a dog, as a primate. Yeah.
Right. So, um, you know, when you see like plankton,
them, you know what I mean? I'll eat the out.
Like a blue whale eat thousands of them. Right. But you know,
when it gets to a certain intellect, a point of intellect, you know,
in an animal, like a dolphin or something like that. Right.
And you can connect and they recognize and all that stuff.
I just think that you can't kill them.
That's tricky though,
because intellect is still defined by what we think intellect
is. But you know, something that sent the end and something,
so many things that aren't even animals have like a true intelligence to them.
Just like, like, like mushrooms and stuff.
Well then we'll stop eating mushrooms. I mean, what the you say?
You know what I mean? I can up a mushroom, loves the mushrooms, man.
Dang. Like, you know, there, everything has, it's really like true it.
Everything is so important. All living things.
Yes. Again, I guess I got to eat some time I've got to eat something.
Right. He's hungry. It's soy something that's living. It's all you eat is tofu.
Sure. There are people who would argue. Yeah. So like, if they,
you can make an argument with that,
that you can make an argument with anything that we eat, like Serratia, like
you mean it's Saracho alive at one point, maybe, you know,
or Tabasco you, yeah. Pepper. It's a pepper, right? Yeah.
Peppers were alive from a plant. Right. You can eat it. You can't,
you can eat it. You know? So it's like, you know,
you got to draw the line somewhere, sweetie. Right.
And I draw the lines out of octopuses. That's why, when you see stuff like,
you know, the Ulan dogging and eating festival, it's an outrage, you know,
just because, um,
and I never thought that I know it's so weird because I used hate dogs and
cats and all animals. You didn't hate them. You just didn't know.
I honestly like when my friends don't talk about
things, you, you know what I mean? I thought you would talk about hurting one.
No, no, never hurt one, but like that's hating to me, my friend.